je suis très respectueux de chacun des
guests chacun des rappeurs qui qui osent
venir
jouer un rôle même s'ils jouent leur
propre rôle tout ça est quand même de
l'acting et c'est pas semblé c'est pas
donné à tout le monde
[Musique]
c'est la confrontation entre profs qui
est une légende du rap français qui fait
ses débuts devant la caméra en tant
qu'acteur et bosh qui joue le rôle de
carnage qui est aussi quelqu'un qui a
fait ses premiers pas devant ma caméra
lors de la saison une seule voiture en
jetons col il termine la discussion sont
âgés et insu le charisme et l'histoire
de rohff face à la légende que j'ai
créée autour de carnages et de ce
personnage avoir cette confrontation dès
l'écriture c'est quelque chose qui me
faisait vraiment
rêver de les avoir et c'est pour ça que
c'est moi qui tient la caméra ce jour là
c'est moi qui cadrent je voulais pas en
perdre une miette je l'avais écrit je
l'avais imaginé dans ma tête et je hais
je voulais le film mémoire c'est le
premier moment où l'alpha va rapper dans
cette série c'était un moment très
important dès l'écriture parce que c'est
un moment miroir avec ce que atik apache
à faire en saison une au moment où ira
prison pour mineurs dans le studio de
fret de sky et là il fallait aussi que
laetitia nous envoie une grosse
performance
je n'ai pas de mots
alors cette photo c'est le premier jour
du tournage des premiers plans de ces
tags maui qui fait son retour en france
on se connaît pas bien on apprend à peu
à se connaître
là des techniques d'acteurs américains
il vient au moniteur il vient vérifier
des choses il vient proposer des choses
et et puis pour tout le monde cette
photo elle nous fera toujours pensé à ce
premier jour de tournage dans une prison
dans des conditions particulières tourné
en univers carcéral c'est toujours
particulier c'est y elle face à à coffs
de rappeurs marseillais qui pour la
petite histoire sont du même quartier et
c'est dans ce quartier contournent cette
scène après vingt-quatre rien bon alors
c'est quand même prendre de toute façon
que nous taisons murder
aller
car je suis très reconnaissante tous
ceux qui viennent et qui ont courage de
le faire et puis je suis aussi très
reconnaissant parce qu'ils apportent
avec eux à chaque fois
leur image ils apportent avec eux leur
public et cette série elle elle est
devenue ce qu'elle est en grande partie
grâce à eux